Ryan sent this to me and said fans want
us to react to this video I'm already
worried oh dude I know this guy where do
you know him from he watches content a
lot for reference this is how hairy my
butt is right now
is to squeeze this cream on what the
Ryan dude Ryan
why did I see another man's butthole
before I see my own he's the first
butthole I've ever fart hasn't even seen
his own butthole yet it's 10 a.m too
Rodney took that away from me it's way
too early it's a Friday morning we're
not getting demonetized for this just
going on patreon
why do you watch this dude all the time
yeah what are you watching I like I like
the way he explains complex topics